do you take let's say a bathroom tap  right here in the united states faucet a  5k take a far set  right so take a tap right right  and turn it on  just so it's dripping virtually nothing  but virtually nothing just a just a tiny  little drip not like a drip every minute  but it looks like a drip yeah drip drip  right like that and it's not going to  change from the drip it's not going to  suddenly create a stream it's always  going to drip right  take your finger  and put it underneath the drips so it's  not connecting to the drop at the top  it's connecting to the drip that has  fallen from the top bit yeah yeah sooner  or later that drip will turn into a  stream  why does that happen  [Music]  you're shining bright i'm your host the  baby you're my pearl